pourquoi justement il n'y a pas eu
d'émeutes à marseille parce que
marseille si neuville à particulière au
niveau de l'identité en tout cas les
marseillais en ce côté c'est dur à dire
mais oui c'est ça ne te marseillais
avant d'être français n'y a pas l'y a
pas de
pierre datant jamais vraiment vraiment
et aussi merci c'était une ville qui vit
énormément de
du temps où il y avait les colonies donc
à la décolonisation c'est une ville qui
s'effondrait industriellement au niveau
2 est là l'état créé un secteur
tertiaire énorme pour lui sinon
aujourd'hui on aurait 30 % 32 % de
chômage à marseille donc à pareille à
celle ci développé énormément
d'associations les associations entier
ont tissé une sorte de filet sur toute
la ville et je vous garantis que les
gens sur le terrain c'est souvent on me
dit où il des hommes politiques veulent
me rencontrer où on me demande mais
alors vous avez fait du bon boulot en
mars et j'y vais c'est pas moi si vous
voulez rencontrer des gens bien je vous
en présente 23 et forcément ils n'ont
pas trop envie de le rencontrer à eux
ils veulent rencontrer du people
il ya aussi le grand banditisme et ouais
je voulais pas trop en parler oui ça
existe oui oui ça existe le g c'est
aussi ça tient quand même parce que si
tu voyais une caisse
la housse avant les voitures ne brûle
pas voilà voilà ouais mais à marseille
je pense quand même il ya la volonté
toujours de prendre le contre-pied de
paris moi ça me fera parce que je suis
un peu comme ça marseillais d'adoption
mais il ya une haine de paris très forte
dans l'impression des émeutes il peut y
avoir à marseille le jour où ce sera
très calme appareils passée il y en a eu
il y en a eu dans les années 80
d'ailleurs les sociologues lillois qui
disait que marseille avait 20 en avance
au niveau social j'ai eu des grands
maîtres au début des années 80 il avait
failli à vis des citations et ça s'est
vu en plus des des émeutes ethniques où
il y avait eu des sortes de guérilla
entre les gitans les arabes avaient été
bien choisi c'est un bon laboratoire je
trouve pour la france parce que
marseille ait pas de ghetto enfin c'est
ce que ça s'il ya des quartiers très
différents quartiers qu'ailleurs oui
bien sûr il n'y a pas le côté comme à
paris c'est à dire les ghettos sur les
côtés ou dans beaucoup de grandes villes
c'est près des grandes villes
occidentales c'est à dire avec un centre
ville très riche et les quartiers
oui mais
bien qu'à new york ça change et les
promoteurs sont moins masse sur harlem
centrale est couvert le rap en partant à
new york c'est voir ton nom que je vends
à moi j'ai toute ma famille new york
miami los angeles et les [ __ ] tu fais
alors tu es musulman tu vois oui tu as
réagi comment aux caricatures de mahomet
je les trouve aussi laide qui les
caricatures qui était fait sur les juifs
dans les années 30 dans l'allemagne
prenne asie je trouve que c'est un
cessez de ces racistes c'est gratuit et
ça n'arrange rien à la situation c'est
pour ça que je dis à travers ce genre de
caricatures là on nous somme de choisir
notre camp donc il ya des il ya des
caricatures pourquoi s'il avait vraiment
envie de caricaturer pourquoi ils n'ont
pas pris les mollahs ils pouvaient
encore caricaturer ahmadinéjad où les
mots là ça pose aucun problème du moment
en caricaturant mao mais on prend tous
les musulmans et on les met tous dans le
même sac et c'est ce que je dis des fois
on a l'impression depuis septembre 2000
hommes âgés d'impressionner fois de me
réveiller le matin et mollah omar qui
dort à côté de -10 me fait chier comme
ça il me regarde j'ai envie de me
débarrasser tu sais quand j'ai quand
j'étais quand j'étais jeune à la fin des
années soixante dix il y avait un type
un dessinateur qui s'appelait gotlib et
je me souviens j'ai été nourri par sa
est excellent et bandes dessinées de
gotlib que c'était c'était y avait tous
les dieux il y avait il y avait moïse y
avait du l'oeil avait il y avait mahomet
il y avait jésus-christ et il faisait 10
d'immenses partout il se bourrer la
gueule et tout et personne ne disait
rien personne n'était scandalisé moi je
suis très frappé par sa tout le monde se
marrait tout le monde se marrait jus
d'accord avec toi quand tu es scandalisé
parce que ces caricatures moi je trouve
nulle ridicule a déjà sert à rien mais
en même temps en aviron paris pense
qu'on est dans une année dans une
société où ce genre de il ya des gens
qui ont le droit qui doivent pouvoir
avoir le droit de republier ces
caricatures et voilà c'est ça le je
crois le débat qui a là dedans c'est que
moi par exemple au point quand on a vu
ces caricatures on a dit non jamais on
va publier ça c'est pas mais on ne va
pas les publier d'accord mais en tant
d'autres journaux doivent avoir le droit
de les publier sans que ça fasse
d'issoire moi je sais on vit quand même
dans des sociétés on doit pouvoir tout
dire et tout faire 1
mais bon là ça c'est vrai quand il ya
des gens qui ont envie de le faire
qu'ils le fassent après j'aimerais bien
que l'opinion publique au nom de la
liberté d'expression n'aille pas dans
une opinion qui qui est libertaire au
départ et qui finit par être fascisante
à la fin le dal même dans le traitement
de l'information voir que médiatiquement
le meurtre de chaïb qui a eu ces
derniers jours quitte un meurtre raciste
a fait un soir de nos informations il ya
vraiment un problème il ya un problème
général je t'aime par la dernière fois
que je suis venu à l admission de
vulgarisation sur l'islam on a sept
millions de musulmans en france jamais
le film le message est un film de paix
avec
anthony quinn il n'est jamais passé ne
serait ce que sur le service public on a
un problème on a un petit problème qui
est qui et à régler faux moi j'accepte
qui est déjà un pays qui ne croient pas
en dieu il faut que les gens acceptent
aussi qui est des gens qui peuvent être
blessés des gens vous savez par exemple
mes beaux-parents qui sait des gens vous
venez chez eux ils dorment par terre
pour vous laisser dormir dans leurs lits
ils vous ressemblent chez eux mais
vraiment c'est l'hospitalité ces
caricatures de ses caricatures les
hommes blessés ne serait ce que pour ces
gens là ne serait ce que pour les gens
là j'aurais aimé que déjà un truc en
goodies ces caricatures c'est vraiment
des caricatures voyez on est on est
d'accord avec vous croyez pas mais si tu
veux le problème qu'il ya je pense que
ce que je comprends pas d'ailleurs
souvent dans une partie du monde
musulman qui a une attitude victimaire
et dit non non non on doit pas faire ça
mais bien entendu est d'ailleurs le
monde musulman n'aurait pas gueuler
c'est caricatural amis de personnes en
avait parlé il est je trouve ça a été
beaucoup mieux qu'on n'en parle pas
comme d'ailleurs on ne parle pas de
certaines caricatures sur quelle maman
non musulmans qui avait laissé les gens
qui ressemblent aux gens qui font les
caricatures non je crois que même d'en
face attends je parle pas du monde
musulman enfin je parle du monde
musulman enfin toutes ces manifestations
qui a vu dans ces pays là
monsieur je ne crois pas que ce cas de
plus insultant pour l'islam beaucoup
plus que les caricatures c'est les types
qui donnent des images à la télévision
quand il égorge des des otages au nom de
l'islam tu crois pas que c'est beaucoup
plus insultant pour l'islam était beau
parent lui doivent être beaucoup plus
humiliés et beaucoup plus un supporter
marseillais jean labé ou que parent on a
au caricaturiste en sommes là on n'aime
pas on en parle de ce qu'on le dit pas
pourquoi les musulmans ont lieu juste
pas pourquoi ils se révoltent contre ces
gens là et sur qui les disaient mais le
problème le système médiatique est telle
qu'on a en france donne
99,9 pour cent du temps de parole à ces
gens là où du temps d'image à ces gens
là on médiatise la peur aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui est médiatisé sur l'islam
pourquoi arrive l'islam à quel moment le
viennent dans l'histoire des religions
moi je sais j'ai lu marcel gaucher mois
donc à quel moment dois je sais que ça
revient après la grande transgression
chrétienne s'est passé pas innocent
c'est une réforme du site une réforme de
la de la chrétienneté mais ça c'est
grave de religions monothéistes c'est le
grand shiva aujourd'hui d'achat dans la
france profonde beaucoup déjà on n'a pas
pas à l'image d'eads et des terroristes
et des otages y crois que ça y est c'est
me trafic doit pas que tu sais bien on
le voit d'ailleurs on le voit à
marseille on le voit à paris moi je sais
pas ce que j'ai une amie musulmane à un
jour il avait un problème affreux comme
ça dans sa vie qui fait souvent la
première église est allé prier le même
dieu mais c'est ça qui fixe mais il ya
des musulmans qui suivent il est vrai
que ça on en parle souvent à travers des
des choses fiona relatives aux jamais eu
des choses positives alors quand le
rappeur monsieur r 10 la france est une
garce n'oublie pas de la baiser jusqu'à
l'épuiser comme une [ __ ] je suis pas
d'accord avec cette
même même si il a envie de
de passer un message moi je connais
monsieur r je pense que c'est que ces
phrases là je reconnais pas là la
personne que j'aime bien ces phases là
mais malheureusement il s'instaure une
sorte de marketing direct du choc et de
la peur est que certaines et oui mais
oui du marketing de la haine de la
france a piétiné
marketing de la haine des immigrés aussi
en europe
c'est ce que
pour le français il s'est figé bien
réglé c'est une c'est une partie de ping
pong tout à fait c'est une partie de
ping pong auquel auquel ouais il faut
arrêter mais il faut pas excusé
justement les hommes politiques de leurs
responsabilités au delà des rappeurs les
propos de monsieur sarkozy ce week-end
sur lamentable quand il dit
quand une bande de jeunes torturent un
jeune homme jusqu'à jusqu'à le tuer le
mot racaille bien faible il prend deux
situations où il ya eu un acte de
banditisme suivi d'un acte de racisme où
il ya un jeune homme qui se fait tuer il
prend sa visite à argenteuil où il ya
des gamins de 16 ans qui l'insultent sur
le parvis qui fait rimer l'ange et le
jette au visage de la france en disant
finalement dans les quartiers des
tortionnaires potentiel non mais c'est
exactement cela c'est pareil excusez-moi
catch as catch carlier qui qui a une
émission qui te quand même des personnes
intelligentes il est
assez nous sommes censés être bête et
pas avoir fait d'études c'est une
personne intelligente il reçoit un
ancien skinhead sur le plateau qui dit
mais moi ça y est j'ai trouvé ma paie je
me suis converti à l'islam jeune femme
marocaine j'ai bien j'ai trouvé mon
équilibre et il dit faudrait pas
basculer d'une extrême à une autre mais
tu te rends compte sur la même ligne et
cette personne là mais la religion
musulmane et les skinheads d'extrême
droite ici c'est gravissime et de dire
des choses comme ça et voulait pas qu'on
se sente choqué nous on répond avec un
emballage différent de monsieur r mais
fermement est radicalement aussi il faut
qu'il faut que ce pays-là réalise qu'on
est là parce que sinon il me voyez pas
aussi que c'est l'islam doit faire sa
révolution
c'est à dire qu'il doit se démener à la
modernité de la tournée dure divisione
du temps afin vote depuis quarante-six
france a mis 250 enfants ces révolutions
il faut donner du temps c'est pas de
l'argent qui s'est donné une idée comme
ça c'est vrai ça mais c'est une
révolution nécessaire il faut que bien
sûr que les intellectuels musulmans
fassent la révolution elle dit a déjà
été dans l'histoire de rimmel a échoué
non elle est là elle n'a pas échoué là
elle a basculé au xiiie siècle avec moi
ils prendront place
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu